this is the production of Cornell
University
okay so it's a great pleasure today to
introduce Ross ouazzani rods did her
graduate work in Italy and then was a
postdoc with Philip benfey and that's
when I met her and she did this absolute
beautiful work looking at how
developmental regulation interacts with
a cell cycle looking at the downstream
jean mec network of short route and
scarecrow in the cortex endodermal
initial division and found cyclin d 61
is downstream of that so it's absolutely
beautiful and i have been very
interested in how cell cycle interacts
with self identity so I loved her work
when I got that and we've been friends
ever since we met at several conferences
and rahxephon these people who is always
doing something innovative so I always
love hearing what her latest thing is
she's got a beautiful publication in the
Elife with a new microscopy method to
look at protein movement she was telling
you last night about a contraption she
and a collaborator rebuilding to image
multiple routes simultaneously with live
imaging and she does beautiful gene
regulatory network about occupational
analysis she's also teaching a joint
class with the engineering it was an
engineer on computational biology at
North Carolina State University so
welcome Roz and i'm looking for at your
talk thank you thank you everyone for
having me here mr. our friendship goes
back when we were both interviewing for
a job at the same time and I always
cheered for her to get the best offer
because she's in the standing scientists
an amazing person so you're so lucky to
have her here that I'm trying to get her
to the house of the triangle area but so
today what I really like to do is to
defend a couple of minutes and to set up
why I'm working with plans in a broader
topic and then I'm going to tell you
three different stories segments get try
to always tell unpublished story but
things don't develop this fast so I
spend most of the time talking about
published story and the other two they
were just recently published in your
life and developmental biology so they
will be short and I apologize that
they're already published but maybe you
haven't yet seen and I would say just
let's get these stock very informal so
just ask me any question that you want
during the talk and now towards the end
I might be to change the speed of my
talk and need so that everybody is on
board and again it will be about three
story so I stay away for the story
you're most interested in and I have an
outline telling you when you can go to
sleep and when you can wake up or etc
and with that I'll take on thanks again
Adrian to having me here and so my
interesting is really to widen to find
other people these identifying for me
but pursuing some of the grand
challenges of our century and so what
are these grand challenges join our
economy everybody wants our economy to
get better improving our health of
course protecting our environment and in
reaching our youth we are at the
University so we are all agree with
these four great challenges and so when
I am here why plant biology well there
is a fifth and I would say very
important activities feeding our world
and for the graduate student in here at
the talk they is extremely important how
you really position yourself in this
group of amazing scientists and trying
to communicate to your parents the
public what is the need why we need more
food we are a very growing population by
2050 we're going to grow up to 9 billion
people
the Buddha agricultural organization
tell us that we need to increase food
production by seventy percent if we want
to feed the world population and so the
very first things that one would say is
well i'll just plan more cops but the
problem is that another let's say
statistical carry net is that the arable
land is declining and i always joke that
by i work on our obnoxious is a model
plant by 2050 will only see on the
sidewalk a rabid oxy splint and there
will be not much arable land and so
still when I'm talking to my mother I
say well we need to provide more food
the arable land is decreasing she would
say well when I was a kid let's say when
I was a teenager she said we would put a
lot of fertilizer so that even if you
have a smaller length you have a lot of
crop and so we all know from the first
green revolution that that was great but
we know that now fertilizer are starting
to harm the environment so now we remain
with these great ring challenge that we
need more food we have less land and we
want to provide enough food without army
the environment so how are we going to
do that and so I like this date and I
just stole my head of the department
that I probably retire 2050 when I say
well I did anything I could up to that
point to at least feed the little bit
more people but as a beginning what
you're going to see for me is all
research done on a model system hoping
that all the research and efforts we're
putting our model system will actually
be then eventually translated and you
don't need these it was not meant to be
there but that's okay and so focus on
the need feed more people basic a pro
coach is we are trying to re-engineer
stem cell regulations our basic idea
very grounded to the floor I always do
they say I'm very short so I'm very
close to the ground so my idea is very
grounded base if stem cell give rise to
all the tissue and organ of a plant well
if we learn more about stem cell
regulation can we actually modify the
architecture of a plant from the ground
so the idea here is to use everything
that we can gain from these model plant
arabidopsis and then eventually
translate that to none on a rabid oxys
plants and even to our flower cells as
exemplified by the vitruvian man so here
is the talk for which you can stay awake
so you can select leave this is all
unpublished data where I'm going to show
you how we are going to we obtain stem
cell type transcriptional profile of
jeans and then we kind of like head to
gain more information about these we
started to generate a gene regulatory
networks of these stem cells there will
be a little bit from the computational
side and then if you're interested then
in mewling vivo imaging where you can
obtain information about movement of
protein or for example in vivo
protein-protein interaction where you
can get down to the sewage geometry of
protein interaction then I'll wake you
up and tell you about this story and
then the third one will be to let's say
make the life of gratitude and postdocs
better so where we are trying to develop
imaging technique or at least imaging
device the ruling
crees di troops and so I had a wonderful
soft with Miguel saying how I to put is
actually very important even if you need
to sacrifice on something else and so
for the whole three section of the talk
the main role is going to be played by
not only a rabid absence but the root of
arabidopsis and mainly is why we're
reusing a rabid absolute is an extremely
flexible system e allows you to do a lot
of cool things the toolbox in terms of
molecular biology they are fantastic for
all our colleagues and friends have
words words set but especially for the
the sock I would like you to remember to
or just wanna the stem cells that we are
going to talk today are found at the tip
of the root and all the cells derived
from Division asymmetric cell division
of these stem cells and so when a
daughter cells is derived and then
another cell is divided then the cells
are pushed upwards such way that you can
follow time along the longitudinal axis
so we have a developmental time along
the route and then what we have is that
the root is they can give you as a
concentric cylinder and so you can
reduce a 3d space into a 2d space
because all these cells are radially
symmetric with the exception of the
basket but we're not going to go into
the details so we can follow time and
space and so when you can deal with
spacious and portal information the best
tool you could use for me at least was
to use the root and so going into right
away the talk so we were fortunate
enough that we were
able to collect all the different stem
cell marker of the root some we develop
some were from talking with two leagues
and say oh we are trying to get all the
sensor market and these phenomenal
colleagues are just sharing all their
markers even before publication for
great collaboration so we have all these
different fluorescent marker of the
different themselves what we can do what
we can obtain stem cells Pacific
transcriptomics profile but and so that
we can identify stem cell gene how we do
that I'm not going to go too much into
the details but we use fluorescence
imaging so sorting so we can obtain we
can protoplast these plants we obtain to
population of cells non fluorescent
protein and fluorescent protein so that
we have an enriched population of the
different stem cell and then we can do
RNA 60 everybody so far following great
so with these data what we did well this
first point I had to sit down and say
well as cool is it that we want to work
on stem cell we never really show and
there were no data whatsoever that the
stem cell were actually
transcriptionally different from
nonsense oh ok so we had to do that at
first we had to look at our stem cell
and then we said well are those defense
themselves transcriptionally set apart
from non stem cell and so we had data
traffic comic data from let's say Stage
one that contains all the stem cell and
trans amplifying zone where cell divides
very often and then we have a stage to
that contain a long gating cells and
stage three that will contain
differentiated cell and so
from these principal components analysis
so the first point that I want to make
here is a joke when the very first time
I saw these CCA this is the work of my
postdoc angels she is analytic and
computer engineers should never work
with the biologists before and when I
saw that I said wait a second we're
working around be doctors not on
Drosophila embryo what is going on here
and you said no no no I rhenium is on
the right track what you're seeing here
is gene and how they are different from
themselves so if you I always take the
second and actually asking God is good
and if he sees what is the difference do
we have a volunteer here well guided to
that are going to have lunch with me
right so they're going to have a free
lunch let's make it less of a free who
is the graduate student they want to
take the lead and see if you see beside
the Drosophila embryo if you see any
difference if you see that the stem cell
have a different restriction or profile
that denounced themselves where are the
guy who Susan raise your hand but now i
need to PQ only two they're hiding what
is it that you're gonna have lunch with
me I'm going to see you in 30 meters
okay you you kept your hand enough that
you think go ahead beauty in places more
mature cells are further along the right
side of the principal component largely
mm-hmm exactly 3d aspect evidence
community right so vegas points you're
having add extra slice of pizza a
successful ganda because you deserve
this so there was actually very nice
because we saw that yes stem cell were
transcriptionally different than non
stem cell what we realize is that stage
one that contains some of the
stem cells couldn't use for any farther
analogies because we have the stage one
is as we expected close to the central
and the non stem cell so that was a
papers positive results and when you're
starting your lab and you say well am I
going the right direction I said they
seem so yes if we are just looking at
the stem cell type-specific expression
we're going the right direction because
we need their different from non stem
cells and so with that in mind we
identify that are specific for the stem
cell only 100 sorry 1,600 genes of which
200 word transcription factors and so we
know exactly where all these different
genes are expressing which stem cell and
etc and so with that in mind then you
could do a thousand six hundred genes
Willy or 200 transcription factor you
say 200 we can do reverse engineer we
can order to undergo Caroline and good
luck to the graduate students and
postdocs working with all these excuses
right or we could strategize differently
and then we sat down with my postdoc and
say well given a lot of information and
i'm going to give you in a second can we
actually find a way then we ranked one
of these a thousand six hundred gene or
these two hundred transcription factors
will most likely have a major role in
stem cell functions and so we sat down
and we develop a computational pipeline
and i'm going to go into the details in
a second but i wanted to tell you that
is a joke that I'm gonna steal from
somebody else's I just heard when you
have a computational pipeline you really
want to show every single need agree d
details you'd like when you have picture
of your child and you want to show all
the feature of your child to your
friends they don't care much so I'm
going to give you just a brief overview
of this competition but line but I'm
happy to give you any extra details
their unit so the computational pipeline
is based on two major asset so is taking
advantage of spatial temporal data and
so what are these facials in portal data
spatial is all the different stem cell
markers transcriptomics profile so cell
type-specific don't see Tommy profile
and temporal data as I was telling you
the root as in Babs in the longitudinal
axis time so the temporal data is of the
gene expression at every single
developmental time of dude so we had a
beautiful data set already available
from Siobhan Brady showing dividing up
the routine a 12 section that so we
consider that a 12-time point data set
and so the computational pipeline as the
vapors are clustering Stephanie's normal
classic said that everybody may want to
use it mainly based on gene coexpression
the main assumption of it is that if a
gene is expressed in one specific stem
cells and edgy should function index 10
cell so they're practically dividing up
the gene if they're especially specific
to one stem cell or two to three some
tile and etc and then the novel aspect
of this computational pipeline is a
dynamic vision a source inference and is
the basic concept the idea here is that
if you find if you have a regulator you
expected this regulator is controlling a
gene either in the time point of the
same time point or one point point after
and so is
is on a first assumption of Markov where
we saying well given the expression in
time-lapse 0 and 10 laps one what is the
probability that these gene is
regulating these allergy and so you do
these inference throughout the 12 data
point and then the other aspect that you
can have is that you can see if there is
a directionality of regulation so it is
up regulating one gene at the time lapse
one orifice down-regulate ok oh and
those are steps of the network is the
idea here was to look at inter-cluster
connection so first of all considering
just last word guitar for specific stem
cells so that you will look at the
network of genes that function just for
the stem cell and also in third classes
so that they function you want
themselves but they also have a
connection with another central because
all of these are multicellular organism
and we know this series cell to cell
communication and then you're going to
see in a little bit the resulting
network but before showing you the
resulting network you say oh this is all
look good but how can you actually prove
the disease solid and reliable and etc
so computationally we need to do a
couple of step before we can say we are
confident about our and furniture
because we still based on probability
right and so the next two steps are how
we validated in silico practically our
new algorithm so our new algorithm is
the name is Jeanne and you can have a
better name we still have the chance to
change it I really don't like it but
didn't friends for gene expression
network inference from spatial temporal
data horrible name but there's no way
that we can find a better acronym but
I when we were extremely pleased is when
you have a new algorithm generally you
challenge your algorithm through a dream
for now there is a dream 5 competition
where you have other existing algorithm
existing data sets that they are
challenged one against each other and
then you can choose specific matrix for
example precision area under the ROC and
then practically these are indirect
measurement of the ratio of true
positives and false positive and geney's
always perform best and especially the
important access here is if you have a
node of 100 node or a little bit that
100 notes they tell us that will have
very low false positives so that our
graduate student imposed off we'll be
happy to go after jeans because they're
not going to quote unquote waste their
time and the other aspect though that is
currently limitation and we are working
on it it gives us confidence if we model
100 200 gene networks so I told you that
we had a thousand three hundred genes
there were specific for the stem cell
and then it's not by chance but I put
that there are 200 transcription factors
so from now on what you're going to see
is the transcription factor network of
the stem cell because we were highly
confident for just modeling this wand
regime and we couldn't really model
there thousand six hundred gene but
we're working on developing different
staff so that we can deal with many more
genes another way that you can an
additional way that you should validate
new algorithm is with using in vivo data
for example here is an example for
example is an example of a known neck in
a
cell typing the roots where we have
these master regulator downstream genes
and etc and so we compare our new
algorithm with existing algorithms
mainly the one that is often uses
Arachne and what you can see here well
it performs there while I find forth
through positive one post- mainly
because there is a regulation back of
these transcription factors but what I
would like you to see here is the
difference between two pen these two
panels that our new algorithm what it
can do it can find the directionality as
i was telling you so this arrow will
actually tell you who is regulating who
and the sign of the regulation it is an
activator or oppression and the other
thing that you can clearly see is the
different size of these nodes so we use
the matrix that tells you the importance
of the different transcription factor
based on some otha Jesus they could be
outgoing edges so outgoing regulation it
could be on in how many people will loop
these genies involved how many feedback
loop how many by fan look so you look at
the network topology and based on the
left with apology you can infer a
ranking and so you can infer a size of
the notes so that if you were a graduate
student you will not put them much
effort into c2 but you will put much
effort into these APL gene that indeed
we know is a master regulator of flow in
the balance so the next thing you're
going to see yeah go ahead you want an
extra pieces lives I got it anyway
hungry yea big it yes not actually
important the edges are also different
sizes because we have actually weight
associated with it so
the point here when we cluster we do
came in clusters and we run it for ten
thousand times and so based on the
caning some of the G will go in one cell
in one cluster some of them will go in
another closet and so sometimes the
edges don't exist so what we do look we
set a threshold they say is 0.6 and then
we drop all the edges that are less
important so that we don't have that
many directions yes so it's based on the
weight and the number of how many times
these happen throughout the inference
algorithm yes babe the point XS which
that which I buy you it is really time
to go you shouldn't ok so what you have
here is the resulting network any is if
I'm proud of my daughter and proud of
this matters because it's the real very
first feature of all these transcription
factor ah for which there were 20 years
of work and what we can see is that from
these middle parts of the next words we
do really recover all and with the
dollar sign is the happy myself we all
recover genes for which in which ensures
that our data confirming their role in
stem cells specification in stem cell
maintenance route the element so what
these networks is showing just to make
it brief in the middle in showing all
the stem cells that are in all the stem
cells jeans if I important for the
maintenance and then on the side at the
beginning I was calling these this
spaghetti meatball disaster but then
there is a battalion and I can I guess
but then biologically it makes a lot of
things all of these large know
are important for the maintenance
specification of the stem cell and all
of these subclasses then we look into
them and we identify genes that have an
important scene for example specific
stem cell type function so what I'm
going to tell you next is that well we
took to stem cell identity network and
validated that in two different way so
the very first way was to look at the
chromatin immunoprecipitation so
protein-dna interactions of these
specific xylem stem cells so chromatin
immunoprecipitation using these no
interception faster that is actually the
transcription factor was working while I
was a postdoc and then we also look at
my home that's why my own gene
expression data while I was a postdoc of
the induction of these genes and so what
we could find in these network that one
two three four five six five out of the
six bow string gene will confirm by
chromatin immunoprecipitation and by
gene expression profile we still have
one that is not confirmed but we're
working on using new molecular
techniques to see if this is a real
target or is a false positive the other
that I would like to spend or and these
panel was supposed to come up later but
that's okay is the quietest sensor
network so we were fortunate enough that
just recently marcin yep nosky have
shown an important role of these genes
transcription factor entity in the quiet
and sensor we had great work done on
Bravo showing function of this gene in
the platen center but they will and then
we have known player one player to play
there are six that we all know that I
important for you see function and then
we focus our attention of these genes
Tyrion SIA and what we identifies that
you can believe me but I have another
picture with the marketing side where we
see QC phenotype so the QC is these low
hand part is Miley part of the route
this is a little bit crooked it will
need some braces in terms of smiles it
has some crooked question Center and
will we know from many years of work is
they if you don't have a functional
active sensor the D Stokes themselves
that are the collumela stem cell they
differentiate and so will we obtained
with a collaborator a fantastic
collaborator from Spain the inducible
line of these jeans Perry oncea what you
have is that you have extra call you
mellow stem cell and the reason while
I'm saying that this is a PSP I staining
we're in red you can see the start line
so you have during a mutant the starch
granule are really close to the quite as
incentive suggesting that there's no
call you mellow stem cells and here you
see extra layer of Colleen I love
themself and so we did ah and I'm when I
should not show you in the details we
did a mathematical model to predict the
function of fans but has biologists and
there's the reason why the paper is now
your house is under revision because the
reviewers thank you to the reviewer they
ask for more biological data what we did
and they is the same Newton but this
time with the question sensor market so
you can see that it has croquettes quiet
and center we did RNA seek so we look at
the gene expression profile of these of
the gene in these mutant compared to all
types and that day I think I was close
to cry so happy I was because if I take
a second and I go back to all of these
stem cell leash
networks what we find is that seventy
percent of all the stem cell niche and
the one in the question center they're
all down regulated in these families so
we have there were sure root genies
downregulated all the clitoral gene are
downregulated all the other stem cells
genes are all down regulated suggesting
that our network identified amongst the
regulator for question Center function
and stem cells maintenance extremely
happy so there was the pre first part of
the talk was I'm you excited reality
perfect because the rest of the talk
will be just telling you and pointing
you to these paper because unfortunate
we don't have enough data to make
another story so this very first part is
that we develop a gene regulatory
network inference that takes advantage
of any kind of spatial temporal data so
for example we have used now these in
collaboration with them cheap wood and
use tomato leaf development to infer
network involving leaf thickness we use
it for through berry development from
the green to bury to the red story so
anytime you have a time course and cell
type or tissue type or introgression
line data set you can combine these two
data sets and get useful information so
now these are going to be just 10
minutes long and then I'll be happy to
have many more questions just going back
to the initial images that I show you
the roots is a concentric cylinder what
I told usually begin is that all the
different stem cells give rise to all
the different issues through HTML South
Asian and
the works done while I was a postdoc in
philly been fees lab and that I started
while i was in Philip this is a great
collaboration we had was to study a key
aspect regarding this two important
transcription factor they regulate the
asymmetric cell division a one kind of
felt I'd that is the cortex endodermis
initial so in a short mutant you don't
have to remember the name but they will
come up they often show root just
remember that this museum was identify
had a very short short short route and
then Scarecrow was identified because he
also liked this asymmetric cell division
and he only had one ground tissue until
it was named after the wizard of oz they
were two other mutant teeny man and lion
they also were missing some other cell
types and this was I think Cole's k
occur because at that time it was
considered that the ground tissue was
the brain of the root correct I was not
there so I don't put my hand on fire but
remember short teeny tiny with a
scarecrow the one without the brain but
what we know that is not just specific
to this transcription factor we have now
platter of data showing that about
twenty thirty percent of transcription
factor actually moving to keep chill
factor so they move from where they are
produced two adjacent cell layer so this
subscription factor is producing the
basket of the route that he moved to the
adjacent cell layer where activate the
downstream targets careful and then we
know that shirt and scarecrow interact
together to regulate this asymmetric
cell division of the ground tissue and
so we had a mathematical model and we
really never asked the question if the
quantification of this movement
important if we want to have a more
quantitative model and
is the stoichiometry of the protein
complex important you don't know until
you test that right and so we started to
collaborate with the sciences a
physicist that UC Irvine that he started
just back then to use fluorescent
correlation spectroscopy canning
fluorescent correlation spectroscopy to
obtain information about movements of
protein and protein-protein interaction
so I don't want to go too much into the
physics details but it's practically
when you have your sample and you're
looking on there for example a laser
scanning microscope a composer I know
you tend to just have the most beautiful
picture right but the background things
that is going on is that every time you
have a fluorescent protein and it goes
in and out your observation volume that
is your [ __ ] focal objective and when it
goes in and out your observation volume
what it does he emits intensity
fluctuations and if you follow the
intensity fluctuations over time and
over space and then you feat using an
autocorrelation function you can do
indeed obtain information about the
movement the concentration and if you do
a dual fluorescing cross correlation and
you have two fluorescent protein one
that gives an intensive fluctuation in
for example the GFP channel and one that
gives you intensive situation in the red
channel you can cross-correlate and fit
to this cross correlation function and
get information about the stoichiometry
of the protein complex so that for
example you don't care much if these
protein are close to each other so if
you will need to do protein-protein
interaction using fresh but they can
just be in the same protein complex even
if they are far apart they will feel
cross-correlation you will still give
you information about the
protein-protein interactions
ah so this cami region make a question
it depends so it depends on let's see if
I have an image here I know okay the
scanning region to go through two or
three cells so is a few microns I'm
trying to remember top of my head just
few Michaels because the cells in the
root are very small but you can have as
long as you want with no problem let me
walk you through a little bit and see if
I can get from you another question
because so the point here is that with
Russ image correlation spectroscopy is
that you do a scanning of a 2d frame and
we could be as big as you want the
important is that for example that the
pixel size is smaller than your point
spread function so that is more
informative than you can image whatever
you want you will just have longer
scanning but the important is that for
your point spread function at ease the
observation volume of your objective is
tendency around 300 nanometer and you
need to have at least five to six pixels
in each point spread function to have
enough correlation I hope did that
answer your question and so when i'm
going to present you and that we use
these imaging technique in the plan for
the first time is raster image
correlation spectroscopy and i'm going
to go into details in a second then you
can really calculate movements and so
what I want to say here is a second and
tell you that we have to use diffusion
coefficient as a term but that doesn't
mean that your protein are diffusing
they can be actively transported it's
just that the physics terms is diffusion
coefficients but it can be really
actively transported as in this case and
then what I'm going to show you is a
line scan where we can tell really the
intra and intercellular movement of a
protein and the number and brightness so
these are the three techniques that i'm
going to send
nice five minutes to it where we can see
the oligomeric state of the protein at
the cellular level so the raster scan is
really raster of your 2d image so you
trace you send your laser along the line
and then along the frame so that you can
image the cell type of interest or the
two different cell type of interest in
this case it will be cells that contain
the basket sure where we know the
protein is produced and then cells where
the protein moves to and so without
going too much into the details what we
could already see that there is a
differential movement of this
transcription factor in this cell type
versus these other cell type wave pools
and so we knew from previous molecular
data that this could be because in these
in the dermis alleys we're sure would
interact with scarecrow and so we wonder
whether the low movement of Shores was
because of scarecrow and so in this case
we really can quantify this movement and
insignificant and we know that it caused
an asymmetric cell division we can see
that in absence of scarecrow or in a
scarecrow in AI line now in game the
dermis what we have is that shirt now
moves like it will move in the basket ER
suggesting here yes indeed scarecrow is
important for the movement of shows the
other thing that we look is well what is
the movements and how scarecrow
restraints shirts movement and so they
are pcs beta where pcs is frankly
correlating all the intensity
fluctuations along a line to spend
different cells so that you can ask a
question does this protein move from
these cell sides to these cell types be
so kind
vice versa and if there is a
differential movement where these
differential movement is coming from and
so in order for you to actually read
through the heat maps and i'm going to
show you in a second i'm going to just
show you an example if I version so the
heat mac or carpet that we obtain are
going to be looking like that so in the
X Direction is the space in the Y
Direction is sign if the protein is
moving south yourself yourself yourself
in a diffusing browse in this way
without any active movement what you're
going to see in blue is the
representation of the movement between
cells with the diffusion if you said
don't see diffusion so if you only see
blue means correlations of movements
black means no movement if you see that
you only see movement here but not here
then this will be your exemplify heat
map if you said see a delaying the
movement so you will see a art formation
that tells you that is taking some time
for this protein to move from cell to
cell but eventually will move and so we
ask the question well what is the
movement of Shah route from where it's
produced to where he ends up and so what
we can see is that it moves we know that
shirtless move to plasmodesmata the
cytoplasmic collection it moves through
one cell and another through a delay
movement but then when we look at the
direction like the directionality of the
movement so going back to the basket ER
then cannot would correspond to the fact
that at that point sureties moving lower
than in the vascular we can clearly see
that Colonel truth does not move back
into the boxes and so I've shown you
before that if we take away scarecrow he
moves faster
Joe root and so we look at the intra and
Inter cellular movement of show roots in
a scarecrow mute on the ground and
telling us what we find is that you know
scarecrow rnai line we can track that
sure is going back to the passages so
these worlds to show you that indeed we
can quantify the movement and really
give a rout of the movement of these
transcription factors and then we can
also look at how they interact so this
is the background you just need to
believe me here we need to calibrate
every time with the control line that is
anonymous form where for example mono
make form are exemplified by these blue
pixels when we look at Shaw root all the
Khmer state will we see it if you
imagine here is the root this is the
basket always produce and leases the
nuclei of being the dermis where it's
moving what we see is that if there is a
percentage of mono make form of short
just in the vascular while there is a
higher oligomers state in terms of
dimers and Petra male in the in the
dermis where interacts with careful so
again we ask the question if you
interact with scarecrow is the oligomer
state of sure roots affected by the
absence of scarecrow and so what we are
looking here is more or less the same
orientation we can clearly see that in
the nucleus being the dermis we're now
scarecrow is no longer there surely is
just as a monomer and so that's how I
asked the Scarecrow is practically a
bridge bringing together too short
protein and so what we did with took an
additional step and look at the cross
correlation so we label shoulders with
the GSP we label scarecrow with the n
cherry you can clearly see where they
are expressed shows scarecrow usually
you will just look at the
co-localization and say fair enough but
what we actually went
is where they interact how they interact
so this is the correlation map where you
can qualitatively see with the blue dots
where they are interacting in a
stoichiometry 121 and the green dots
where they are interesting as the
geometry of two to one and here is the
stoichiometric Instagram where we can
see that there are mostly one shoulder
thing worse careful with red
exemplifying the highest probability to
find this conception factored in a to
come to 121 but also that you have a
high probability to find to shore route
with one scarecrow and here is the
quantification so everything that I show
you qualitatively we can also obtain the
quantification so eighty percent of
these is of the protein-protein
interaction is one to one and two to one
is limited to fifteen percent so what
I'm telling you all this story I'm
telling you all this story because it's
extremely cool to be and going to
details of identifying the movements and
quantify the movement and the
stoichiometry but the idea we had was to
obtain these information and develop a
mathematical model they will give us
information about the dynamics of these
two transcription factor so this is the
mathematical model that we use is a
series of order differential equation
where we are modeling for example show
notes in the basket or shortening the
dermis and then from our data we know
that there are diamonds of sure routine
ended early so that is the equation for
that aspect and then we have the models
scarecrow and leaves the yield term
because we know the shortest regulates
vehicle and then we have the complex one
to one of shorts scarecrow and the
complex of two to one short escapes all
the information that I told you we
practically retranslate in a
mathematical model it's like you will
translate from the English to the
Italian all of these is what I just told
you from the biology to the mathematical
model
we ran up sensitivity analysis and find
out that diffusion coefficient were
extremely important but let me tell you
what the model tell us and how we
validate it so what these first outcome
simulation of the model tells you is
that we don't know anything about sure
to show these produce and it stays
constant we can do much about that until
we identify upstream regulator short in
the red line is the expression of
scarecrow over time and what you can see
that about 2.5 three hour is when you
reach the highest expression of
scarecrow and that what you can learn
here that as soon as taker is produced
is the requester by Shaw root and you
have the formation of a shirt scarecrow
121 protein complex only with time
taking place at about nine hour we start
to see that the two-two-one scarecrow
short complex takes place and so what we
did we practically validated this
mathematical model by using a short
inducible system where we put a
scarecrow transcription online and what
we can see that after we use show roots
to like will do the mathematical model
the simulation here as soon as we use
shirts at about three hour we start to
see scary expression and that will fit
that very well the other things that we
are now working on is that you can see
that all the solution reaches of steady
state so they reach a plateau what that
means well we know that about 16 to 18
to 24 hours when the stem cells start to
divide but we really didn't have any way
to track and follow stem cell division
over time so these still remain the part
that we're working on and understand
these second outcome of the model and so
the second part of the talk and the next
one out the glance through is okay
is really that scanning pressing
correlation spectroscopy allow you to
quantify parameters that were not there
easy to quantify before and then all of
these quantitative measurements they can
really be put into a mathematical model
that is able to tell you what are the
dynamic of your system and so these that
in this talk I'm telling you it was a
natural progression well we started to
use these before we got these data is to
develop new technology to do long time
course and so the long time course that
I'm talking about is to using a life
sheet microscopy where I'm going to just
tell you not the advantages but the
limitation that we had to overcome so we
did seize them you can grow one sample
that aside and as I was telling you you
need to get high throughput to get your
gardener and pulls off happy so we
wanted to if you want to do a five days
time course then you have and you want
12 biological replica your graduate
student is working for a week for the
next 12 weeks on a single project and
you know how it goes most of the time
experiment fails so it's going to take
six months so that you get one real good
data set so what we did we collaborated
with an engineer in the department of
industrial and system engineer and with
Tim horn and we develop a system that
use the same exact aspects and specs of
the life sheet microscope that we're
using but at this time now we 3d printed
an imaging chamber that we called magic
it was really magic multisample
arabidopsis grows an imaging chamber
where we could imagine least four sample
at a time rather than one so rather than
wait 12 weeks now you get that your
image one plant you rotate these
revolving chamber you image the second
plan you rotate so you have for
biological replicates right there so you
reduce a lot of time in the cost these
things cost a lot
and so currently we have a prototype
that olds more than four because we want
to run just a couple of biological
ratikan and I binocs statistics so we
tried out the system using a marker for
cell division and currently we use in
existing pipeline in community but we
are working with the lasik and computer
engineer craniums Williams amazing
collaborator in the field to develop our
own automatic image pipeline to
calculate cell division coming over
coming over time especially for the stem
cell we validated this is the existing
pipeline we're happy to share is
practically coming up from Fiji so
extremely useful when we could be able
to measure was all the different new
cell division using our system and using
the existing system from vice and that
you can see that along the time our
system plans are very happy and they
keep on dividing you want that and so we
image more plans for more than 48 hours
and the nice part is that now we can do
a lot of experiment where we change the
design of these chamber where we can do
drug treatment that temperature
treatment because we have a temperature
sensor and so on so forth so the end of
the talk is kind of like the take home
message different talk but all together
our umbrella question is how can we
really understand stem cell regulation
so that we can manipulate them cell
regulation and so is really the
triangulation and work of biology
computational biology and develop a new
technique and so there was exemplified
by modeling cell-type specific
expression and the idea here again my
good friend the vitruvian man
is eventually so there are known animal
stem cell network player can we actually
obtain the end full plant stem cells
genes in a rabid dogs and so this is no
picture but a couple of more people were
added to the group but this is the core
group we started with worth today that
i'm showing you was from the postdoc
angeles louisville a gear analytic and
computer engineer PhD my PhD student
adam and natalie and then very
collaborator from NC State engineers
Timothy horn and cranium channels
Williams and great collaborator
throughout and funding from NFS Korea
grant and a bi-lateral grant with the UK
and NSF dbcs egrants and we did I take
any question and so sorry that I ran at
the clock I'll take any questions I know
was a lot I hope you left a little bit
in between oh geez / studies the first
thing you do get your roots for the
starry seek and you die just a syllable
fellation sit there and make it I
selected the photo class right whoops oh
you'd love the simplest you communicate
and presumably sell their enormous
distress so do you have an idea what
that does the overall story at your gene
network non don't you see if he's a
concern that we all keep in our best
mine to do the protoplast thing what I
can tell you is that all the different
lines are treated with the same way so
if there are genes that are
differentially regulated by the actual
protoplasm system they will be discarded
because they will have the same change
in expression over sample
the other aspect is that we need to get
some type specific expression and that
is so far what we can do bad but yeah
you're right we is hour and a half
protocol for which yes a lot of gene
will change their expression profile
because of the stress but you should
normalize and lose this gene and so
probably we will lose some jeans but the
point here is at least the gene that
you're going to go after like for
example the tree oncogene clearly show
the heads of rolling the stem cell
function yeah I mean you can file a
little approach that makes a CAPTCHA to
see Justin better for someone removal of
people doing that so um so we are doing
laser capture but for example we are
doing laser caption where we cannot do
for extra activities of Sony so we have
a project with the popular trees where
we can clearly show and follow the
morphology of the stem cell for
secondary growth and we do laser capture
but for example for these those are very
teeny tiny rules and so it's not that
easy is it not that easy yes but good
point one could think to do in fact or
so on but so far we're happy will we get
but is is always you need to keep that
in your backpack yes so does apply for
the job or is pretty cool so after and
early did you consider about the
movement no such as christian factors to
measuring the fertilizer yeah you you
are too young point you want to come in
my lab and work in my lab please do
because I'm always telling my graduate
student can we in any way from the gene
regulatory networks in first we charge
the genes that are actually moving or
etc we will not be able to until we also
have protein information but they is a
key point these gene move around and so
we should get to the point where we
develop
computational model that predicts which
transcription factor movies but I think
we need to get to the protein level and
add overlay the trunk atomic and the
proteomics so far the limitation is that
with trans Khatami RNA and DNA you
amplify you can start with very little
material with proteomics we are not yet
there to get cell type-specific
proteomics profile yeah so going back to
that question is what Jo shine so much
on so when you do that principle
component in that yes one of the
questions people always show principal
component analysis but never tell us
what the components what were the basis
the components that you're doing that
and it gets back to javas classes
because our their components of their
gene expression that you could more
easily explained associated with making
protoplasts and ours too so we are in
the doing warrior telling for the
project with the hookah and very long on
I on the teaching condition in flow and
development we are indeed looking more
into this specific of the different pc a
component mental for these it was just a
simple let's say way out to say well am
i crazy or not the best m seller
different than on stem cell because that
is actually the ground truth if they
would not have been different why to do
the work that i'm doing so yeah but it's
a good point i just i just actually fed
in the talk that explain exactly what
you're saying and I went to my postdoc
and I said you need to look into these
because we need to really show for these
other projects yeah they are completely
right when I have a question so I don't
know much for the Scarecrow and I look
you today but it's wonderful you show
you once once if you want to geometry
for me and then for a dime is two to one
and one and so I kind of wonder whether
it's just something to do with this
portal activity yeah now is beautiful
question Elena so
a society that I really wanted to show
the new set of data but they were just
sooo preliminary so when I gather
students and that goes back to your
question well my graduate student saw is
that in another yourself where they're
both expressed the quiescent sensor the
stoichiometry is actually flipped around
and we will see so we see that we have
to schedule and one shoulder and what we
have seen is that you have a too short
one scarecrow right starting when the
cell will be close to division so the
stem cell the CEI the stem cell divides
about 18 to 24 hour it / symmetrically
while the quiescent sensor is a less
mitotically dividing cells but
eventually divides a 72 hour or what I
would like to see for example does
history geometry changes in the quiet
and sensor if we if we treat with
brassinosteroid the question centers
divides faster so what we're trying to
do is to see the stoichiometry changes
if there is a change in the south
division so that we can link that and
start to see a correlation and then go
after the causation it is really the
stoichiometry underline the timing of
divisional us yes we don't know wait
wave today's why I like I hope I could
show this data testing this is not
serious question oh go ahead i'm not a
serious anything is you're not a few
speakers for sure she can't assess the
world is going to be better spent uh
yeah I'm is a is a good point it's so
the point there is rather than convince
my mom that the world would be rather
fat is a message that I would like to
say
and saying he's always important to take
five minutes and see why we're doing
what we're doing because it's very basic
what I'm doing is basic biology and so
if I were to tell my mom what I'm doing
she would be you too I don't get it but
if I'm telling the big picture then she
says I'm so proud of you and so they
hope is that we'll be able to live so
Dave mainly for graduate student and
postdoc always try to feature your
research in a broad context so that your
parents are probably and they give you a
present so we want to know Smith the
graduation luncheon sit for 30 min
library's website called again this has
been a production of Cornell University
on the web at cornell edu